nfl total access the show that i helped
launch in 2003 congratulations to them
that's great
getting nominated for best studio show
daily and part of the reason why is
because people tune in to hear what ian
rapport's got to say and my buddy
rapsheet joining me here on the rich
island show how are you congratulations
rick it's kind of cool thanks brother
same to you man because you're you're on
total access and good morning football
quite a lot and uh
i appreciate you joining uh joining us
here in advance of
a huge week coming up next week on the
nfl draft uh
yeah why would the dolphins want to
trade out of six when they trade back up
into six as part of that big huge uh
deal a few weeks ago what's going on
there so here is kind of my
understanding of
where the dolphins are so obviously they
were at three and then they took the
huge bounty of pitch to move back to 12
but if you're at 12
you're sort of kind of out of the mix
right like you
you lose the ability a little bit to do
whatever you want and you don't get to
almost control it i think the idea is
when you're at six even if you have to
give up a first round or to do it which
obviously the dolphins did
um you're much more being you're much
more in control of your own
fate so they trade up now they trade
back they trade up
and now let's say quarterback slides
to them then someone who wants to come
up like they can basically hold them
hostage and go
we're gonna get the quarterback premium
twice
that's basically the thought is say like
we're gonna make sure that someone
pays us to draft their own quarterback
two times not one time
which increases their draft hall
so okay um
i i still i get it i mean but at some
point you got to hit the draft it now
button right
i mean you're right and like let's say
you know let's say kyle pitts is there
at six
to me they probably just take him i mean
that's a guy who
i've spoken to i don't know how many
people but 25 pages worth of notes
and i haven't had anyone find anything
wrong with kyle pig almost funny it's
like quentin nelson a couple years back
like everybody loves them
um so maybe the dopplers just take them
otherwise
like they're gonna be able to get some
incredible value they might trade
try it again so okay kyle pitch isn't
lasting till
six right i mean not that may uh there's
there's i i mean that would mean four
quarterbacks
and then um jamar chase
or or or or penne sewell
right uh to the bengals and thus that
that's the glorious heavens opening up
for
kyle pitts to stay in the state of
florida and play professional football
that's the way that would be yeah i
would say the only way that kyle picks
goes to six or you know sort of last to
six which is
again possible is if the falcons take a
quarterback and they have looked hard at
the quarterbacks
um i know something peter king mentioned
and i would echo this
that arthur blank very much wanted his
people to at least
take a hard look investigative look at
the quarterbacks
that is something he wanted as an owner
to make sure that
whether or not they drafted one they
were ready to draft one
so that means the falcons are in the
quarterback mix
possibility whatever so if the falcons
take one
then i think pitts probably falls to the
dolphins and then
you know then it's either do they trade
out or do they just take
maybe the best player in the draft not
named trevor lawrence see i i guess
if the the one thing again though is is
um
and chris greer deserves an amazing uh
amount of credit and respect for what he
is doing at the general manager position
in miami and that is
that is that is a very long alt with all
due respect
i'll be very honest because at some
point though
and you know get the guy you want you
want kyle pitts you've got a million
draft picks go get kyle pitts call up
the
falcons and say we want them and you
know that the bengals i mean the falcons
would just run the risk of of
hoping the bengals don't trade out you
know they're not going to take the
quarterback that you might want
and go down to go down to six and get
the quarterback you want anyway
you know i know that that you do run the
risk of that but
the dolphins at some point you know it
just reminds me of the sixers they
masked all those picks and eventually
they did turn it into players and had to
go away with them
right that's just that's why hearing
that hey the dolphins might trade out
again i'm like that that kind of
made me stop and go home you know ian
you know yeah it made it kind of made me
also um but it makes sense because
it makes sense in this way if you
if someone is going to take a court like
let's assume right now
that the dolphins have their franchise
quarterback right which i'd say across
the nfl is
much more of an open question than the
dolphins would like but
they believe into us so let's assume for
the sake of argument they believe in tua
and
their quarterback question is over if
that's the case
then i don't mind them gouging everyone
else for a quarterback because
you know kyle pitts is i think going to
be a great great player and everybody
loves him absent that
there's some maybe some similar players
up until
like the 12th to the 13th person in the
draft then it
kind of flattens out a little bit so you
have like a group of great great players
probably up to 12 or 13 and then you
have everyone else so as long as you can
stay in that mix theoretically
you're going to be getting a great
player anyway maybe just get the capital
that's
that's be that would be kind of my
explanation for the dolphins and in the
end you know we'll see what the ones
doing
ian rappaport here uh on the rich eisen
show uh the draft sometimes can be like
a solar system ian and uh
trust me i'm sober um and when i make
this analogy
uh and by that i mean that there's a a
fixed presence
and then we in the media are all
orbiting around it and we just have
different perspectives of the same
fixed presence um over time
um and the fixed presence the sun is the
the
the third overall pick and the son of
mike shanahan who gets to control it
and we're all orbiting around it and on
one side of the sun we see
mac jones and now we're coming around
there's there's justin fields
and yet the niners haven't changed who
they want right i mean would they trade
it up to go get they they
have they was the second pro day changed
or
you're hearing something different or
we're all hearing something different
what what is going on here
yeah i believe that going into the
second pro day
cycle or whatever that was the 49ers had
a leader in the clubhouse and they were
looking to confirm that
i don't know for sure for sure right now
whether or not
they did confirm it but that is my
belief of what was happening
so the weirdest thing for me in this
whole thing and i'm not
uh i'm not into the gambling world at
all and i guess considering the deal
that the nfl just struck i probably
should at least find out about it nice
um but somehow justin fields is the
odds-on favorite to go number three and
i cannot and for the life and we figure
out
what happened in the last week to make
that happen like i don't
i just don't know that anything actually
did
to me still i would say
mac jones is the guy to look at there um
and you know maybe they've kept it all a
secret they've hoodwinked us and
you know kind of like the bears did with
trubisky which you know congratulations
if that happens but
i will stick with mac jones until
until i'm convinced otherwise i'll say
that well i mean every talent evaluator
i've spoken to uh believes that um
you know fields is is the better talent
than mac jones
with the ultimate ev that's everybody i
mean
i haven't heard somebody say i would
take mac jones over justin fields our
colleague bucky brooks
uh said it best saying that fields and
lance
are are far better athletes than mac
jones has the major upside
um that mac jones is like iron man where
alabama's
uh team and program and coaching staff
for like the suit that makes him the
super power you know
and um maybe that's what it is maybe
we're just hearing from all the
the initial reaction was well mac jones
fits
and now two weeks later a pro day later
and two pro days later with lance having
his
that maybe that's it i don't know i i i
that that's the question mark here
i don't get it yeah and maybe i i do
i've never heard that description of the
iron man thing but it kind of does make
sense
so the the background the sense or
whatever you'd say i get on mac jones is
this
he has a a great mind total recall
he has brilliant um i would say for kyle
shanahan
and for mike shanahan who loves him also
you know his brilliant mind
matt jones's ability of mine is
something that is insanely important
to them right something they can build
around and use assuming that is the pick
i i haven't heard you know trey lance's
evaluation goes up and down the game he
played last year wasn't great
everybody loves the talent he's very
smart it just might take a while
so you know you don't you're not going
to know what you're getting immediately
justin field i really haven't had anyone
knock him very much at all i mean he's
had some up and down moments but some of
the up moments like the clemson game
have been incredible
so i think it's more just like most
people i've spoken with rich
believe that justin fields is number
three quarterback in the draft
i just don't know that that list
includes the 49ers right now
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show and then um
usually in an nfl draft but not always
and i don't know if this year is that
um that there is a um a storyline that
that took up tons of the oxygen pre-free
agency during free agency and post that
dies down
and then per you know bursts back up is
russell wilson that
this year you got one for me um at all
ian yeah i mean russell russell wilson i
think
in my humble opinion i think we've
probably
talked enough about that this off season
uh don't worry though
uh if you like the russell wilson
storylines this offseason we can always
do it again next off
we actually might be traded right um you
know the desean watson thing
i would not say is over we still have so
much to sort out
his legal situation we have a team that
has not yet been willing to trade him
and he has still privately said he
doesn't plan to play for them so
something must happen there i don't know
what it's going to be but
something must happen um i think that's
going to be the one that we still need
to figure out the russell wilson stuff
i'll put a pin in that and we'll talk
about it all next off season don't worry
so okay so let's not look for a trade
right there and
and then desean watson if if his what
everyone in the media refers to as his
situation had not uh
arisen you know this would be the time
where it our first 10 minutes of our
conversation would have been all about
who might get
desean watson and could the jets trade
number two overall and stuff like that
for him and
but that that's just not getting handled
and finished
and to the point where we we understand
what watson's standing with the league
would be
let alone his team let alone his
community
let alone uh the legal system we have
we're well i think we're a long time
away from that this just seems to be
getting uglier
and uglier and and murkier and murkier
without any sort of
um uh i i guess uh culmination
down the road ian this sounds like this
going into the summer forget about the
draft week
yeah i mean i i don't i don't know about
all that because
there's i would not rule anything out
with the
sean watson situation at all i just i
wouldn't i don't know what's going to
happen
um but i know these things can turn on a
dime very very quickly so
you know will it last like an actual
second like an actual dime is that what
you're saying
like seriously like because that you
know a settlement
where where this if you will goes away
from the court
system and from the the headlines that
would then lead to well
what is the league going to investigate
what's the team going to do
like that's where that would then head
into so is that right
are you are you you're again this is
are you referring to that that's
something that's possible
in the near future i mean where it
stands right now is
deshaun watson has not obviously has not
wanted to settle because
he hasn't settled it's like when you
know trades haven't happened because
there's been no agreement like there's
been no
you know i haven't gotten any word that
he would settle okay um
a settlement would probably accelerate
things
and cause everyone to declare what they
actually want to do like i've also
i would also say like i still don't know
what the texans would or wouldn't do
they have made no
you know they have not said at all that
they would consider a trade
if there was a settlement would they
consider one
i don't i don't know it's just i i don't
want to say that anything
at all is decided right now because
there are literally seven things
that need to happen before we know
anything on the walking situation
okay before i let you go what are we not
looking at what's the story that uh
nobody's talking about right now for the
draft um
for next week give me something you know
i think we
we've hit on a lot of them um we've
probably spent a lot of time
on top ten i would just say the couple
things that i would keep my eye on
um not a lot of great edge rushers in
this draft
and very few great great tackles
so you kind of wonder what people might
trade up for
not talking quarterback i would say
you know you may trade up for a pass
rusher because there's just not that
many
you know maybe jalen phillips is the
first and maybe someone comes up for him
um
and then if pine soul goes early
who else trades up for a tackle that
would be kind of my next question
because quarterback's important
tackles next most important there's not
a lot of options and there are a lot of
teams that still need tackle
what about a quarterback to be traded
back into the first round four
that might that would give us six well
what do you think is that possible
really interesting
yeah because you know to me uh online
and you have davis mills
i would describe both of them as highly
regarded
and then you look at the back of the
first round then you have the saints
who you know i don't know what they have
at quarterback but
could they draft one early and and kind
of add that person to the mix
maybe um could the steelers draft one
possibly you know could the bucks who
have tom brady
who resigned their number three
quarterback but not their number two
quarterback
could they draft one possibly so
you know could a sixth quarterback sneak
into the first round out of lamar
jackson i would say
that is a definitely a fun storyline as
we get to like 10 30 at night or
whatever it is on thursday
i will be wondering along with you and
speaking of the steelers before i let
you go
ian uh that's so i lied i'm not going to
let you go based off of that last one
i mean a coach gets a three-year
contract extension as opposed to
going and coaching into his walk here
normally that that would get a ton of
headlines and play and what have you
with mike tomlin it's just a shrug i
mean the steelers
honestly i was born in 1969 they still
have only three coaches in my 51 years
on this planet
it is remarkable how much of a shrug it
gets but that happened today i know
steelers are amazing they really are
they have to be one of the best run
franchises in all sports right i mean
they and what's crazy too
with a wild higher young brash
thin resume african-american
um and the guy he was you know sort of
battling
was like a lot of coaches at that time
an older white guy
and the steelers went against the grain
hired someone they believe in
and it might have been i don't know one
of the best hires in sports history
i mean tom was amazing and
he got another three-year deal he's
probably going to coach forever
he will i mean i can't imagine any
situation where he's not coaching his
dealers until he retires but he's
he's awesome and i think it's an awesome
organization real quick you were cutting
in and out who was the guy that the
steelers didn't hire
that was down to tomlin and who after
cower who was that again man was it
was it less grim i'm trying to remember
now right
it might have been because he was right
well i mean
and i also remember i believe it was our
colleague mike silver reporting for
sports
illustrator that had a bombshell of a
scoop
that says it might be that was saying it
might be common everybody went crazy
uh i apologize rich since you're going
to let me go i need to take this call
go for it and you take care brother
that's ian report there you go
that's the name of his memoir i have to
take this call
breaking news that was right you know
i'm sorry i just don't want to let
people go
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here